sauver les apparences la première
ministre nord-irlandaise en déplacement
dans une école primaire pour fêter un
anniversaire des plus spéciaux lille
fête ses 100 ans
un gâteau et une chorale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un sourire toutefois de circonstance
mercredi 28 avril
arlene foster a posé sa démission un an
après sa prise de fonctions l'avenir de
l'irlande du nord plus que jamais en
suspens je suis entré pour la première
fois à l'assemblée en 2003 et le voyage
de ces 18 dernières années a sans aucun
doute été mémorable nous devons tous
apprendre à être généreux les envers les
autres à vivre ensemble et à partager ce
merveilleux pays
l'avenir de l'unionisme et de l'irlande
du nord ne se trouvera pas dans la
division arlene foster défonceuse de
l'appartenance de l'irlande du nord au
royaume uni quittera la tête de son
parti unioniste démocrate le 28 mai et
son poste de premier ministre fin juin
[Musique]
une décision liée au futur conséquences
économiques du break site pour le pays
le break sites ayant ravivé les tensions
au sein même de l'irlande du nord en
paix depuis 1998 après un sanglant
conflit de trente ans en faisant 3500
morts unionistes protestants d'un côté
de l'autre républicains catholiques et
défenseurs plutôt d'une réunification
avec l'irlande
je pense qu'il y a plus affaire avec les
dirigeants politiques et les politiciens
c'est le type de mots qu'ils utilisent
qui répand la peur dans des communautés
comme celle ci les mécanismes exacts de
cette nouvelle frontières douanières en
mer d'irlande et les conséquences
exactes qui en découleraient n'ont
jamais été expliqués aux communautés
loyalistes d'irlande du nord
je pense qu'elles ont été quelque peu
choqué la création donc d'une nouvelle
frontières douanières en mer d'irlande
au centre des débats le break site
désormais acté après des semaines de
négociations l'irlande du nord est
finalement resté au sein du marché
européen
ce qui signifie donc des futurs
contrôles douaniers et sanitaire entre
la provence britannique et le reste du
royaume uni
une situation considérée donc comme une
trahison pour les nord irlandais
unionistes et amoureux de l'union jack
toutes les générations sont en colère et
frustré par ce qui se passe ce satané
protocole est une invention européenne
et il est destiné à m'enlever mon
caractère britannique à proximité des
murs de paix à belfast mois d'avril 80
huit policiers ont été blessés au cours
de plusieurs nuits de violences